faut que tu le rideau aux hommes il
attend divers la difficulté moléculaire
vous attrape en pleines répétitions de
la pièce les chaises de ionesco ici au
tnm
pourquoi avoir accepté un tel rôle un
tel défi mais parce que c'est une grande
pièce et que le metteur en scène est un
maniaque de ionesco et que mon
partenaire idéal les 6 heures de le
premier dit il fait déjà nuit
tu te rappelles jadis n'était pas ainsi
il faisait encore jour à 9h du soir à
10h à 1008 pourtant vrai yens mémoire
les chaises de ionesco ses 540 de
répliques
oui un texte archives c'est la joie
vous trouvez votre besoin pour agir et
tout votre pc abbas et c'est plaisant
quand on en énergie quand on sait notre
texte et on l'a travaillé beaucoup
beaucoup de textes tellement un texte
merveilleux qu'est ce que vous laissez
les gens se demandaient pourquoi
pourquoi ils sont comme ça parce que il
pleut il pourrait avoir 45 50 ou 90
c'est une fable il ya un escroc parle
beaucoup de la mémoire des souvenirs et
nous avons tous un souvenir lié à mon et
couleurs moi je suis la génération
montréal pq building ma maison l'a
toujours été
et j'entends bien qu'elle reste je vous
en prie faites ce que vous demande
d'autres vont se souvenait par exemple
de satyam va aussi accueillir tout le
monde j'aime ça d'un conseil voulait
donc exécution le matin pardon mais à
travers tous ces rôles lequel ouvre le
plus souvent ben ces deux là d'abord
parce que 6 7 2
ces deux grands auteurs et c'est drôle
parce que dans non dans les deux mon
amoureux déjà gonnet 7e n'a et sa
montréal pq que je trouve je me permets
de dire c'est pas pour mon porte monnaie
on devrait repasser cette grande série
la note laura elle est présent dans
toutes les filles qui dansent passent
leur temps à commettre des péchés
mortels
vous avez parlé de votre porte-monnaie
toute votre carrière diabétiques
pigistes et l'actualité nous rattrape on
parle beaucoup de parité salariale
hommes femmes
oui j'aimerais avoir votre point de vue
là dessus ben il faut qu'il faut que ça
marche que les femmes soient traitées
également mais moi j'ai souvent négocier
des contrats quand on était à 2 pour mon
partenaire masculin
oui oui celui à moi j'étais paraît-il
une paix négociée à trice d'après est
arrivée la mode entre guillemets des
agents y avait pas d'argent à ce moment
là on négociait soi même on se trouve
dans votre loge
oui et on dit que vous prenez bien soin
d'apporter de vos objets j'ai remarqué
qu'une photo de jean besré oui parce
qu'avec lui j'ai joué de vrais de ces
hausses de ionesco
c'est cela la photo avec jean besré il
savait c'est quand ça fait exactement 50
ans c'est important pour vous de vous
approprier le suspense avant de m
ben il faut qu'on soit chez soi autant
que possible dans le temps les théâtres
des fois on était huit dix ans en ligne
comme cela et puis moi j'aime bien aussi
mentouri de photos de gens avec qui j'ai
joué avec qui je vais jouer de ma
famille s'est passé comme si me protège
un peu de superstition ah bon un peu oui
un peu oui c'est sûr c'est sûr quand
j'entre en scène je place mes parents
dans des spots mais là malheureusement
jorat trois spots de plus parce que j'ai
perdu mes deux petits soeur et mon petit
frère
c'est beaucoup et alors je réponds ils
vont pas loin cinq spots pour chaque
jour vous ne met pas par une boîte rage
alors j'aimerais qu'on parle de votre
éternelle jeunesse
votre je veux votre recette ben il est
le travail le travail sa gardant vi
c'est stimulant il ya des gens qui
arrêtent de travailler à 65 ans la
fameuse retraite y retrouve puissant
nuit hommes et femmes il ya d'ailleurs
la grande chanteuse nana mouskouri qui a
été interviewé elle avait arrêté est
devenu comme folle et recommence cela
fait une énorme tournée va passer 80 ans
est en pleine en pleine forme c'est sait
si c'est le travail qui tient en vie
autrement les gens sont amorphes
les ennuis est ce une flore monsieur ou
un berceau un poirier ou un corbeau et
non tu vois bien que c'est un tableau la
semaine prochain aura lieu la première
oui les chaises de ionesco un brin
nerveuse un gros brin fébrile fébrile
c'est tout à fait normal mais c'est
comme à chaque fois c'est la première
fois les gens disent mais en
vieillissant vous habituer non c'est
pire mais vieillissant parce qu'on est
plus conscient un 7-1 au théâtre je n'ai
pas le trac moi je voyais les gens
s'énervaient autour de mon trac
aubin il est arrivé de trois ans plus
tard elle ne connaît maintenant le
connaît et ça augmente alors monique
miller je vous dis le beau timbre
je le prends avec plaisir